clover 19 has posed the biggest
challenge to britain
and the world since world war ii this
week we've spoken to those on the front
line of the uk's response to the
pandemic
and tonight the people in charge of that
response face the public
this is covert crisis learning the
[Music]
lessons
[Music]
good evening i'm sophie ridge over the
last two nights we've heard from
government advisors
experts and victims of covert 19. in a
project with tortoise media sky news has
gone through
the details and the data behind every
significant moment since coronavirus
first emerged a year ago
events that have affected us all
and tonight the public will have their
chance to question those in power
and pass their verdict a hundred people
of all political persuasions from across
the country
representing the whole of british
society welcome
to all of you welcome
facing then we have two of the people at
the very heart of the uk's response the
senior government minister
in charge of the vaccine rollout nadine
zahawi
and dr susan hopkins of public health
england welcome to both of you
now before we get to the questions from
the audience i've just got one question
that i'd like to ask
everybody from myself so to our two
panelists
and also to our audience as well so if
you just raise your hand if you would
if you know somebody who's had covet 19.
so this could be yourself
it could be a friend it could be a
family member if you know somebody
who's had covered
i mean it's pretty incredible to see it
that is nearly everybody
it really is nearly everybody and i
think that just underlines how this is a
pandemic has touched
all of our lives in in so many ways
it really really does thank you for that
well let's crack on shall we let's go to
our first
question this is from carly mortimer and
carly you've got a question about
following the signs what's your question
okay um why will the government not
follow the advice that the scientists
give
regarding a full lockdown the government
who are not clinically trained
seem to think they know better and go
against their advice
if we had all done what these scientists
have been saying surely we wouldn't be
in a worse position now
than we were a year ago okay that's the
question there from carlos i want to put
that directly to
nadeem to hawaii why will the government
not follow the advice
of the scientists that's what carly's
asking
carly thank you for your question and i
would say we've always followed the
advice but of course
we've learned more about the virus as
we've
gone along and i know susan will talk in
more detail about
for example when we discovered the
asymptomatic
uh infection rates are very high uh with
this
virus and had to rapidly change
our policy on this last year and of
course
it's worth reminding everyone that the
prime minister received information on
the 18th of december
on the new variant that's more
infectious uh which has caused the
second
uh uh a big big spike uh in both
hospitalization and sadly death
as well uh on the 18th of december he
discovered
he was given that information on the
19th we moved
into what is then called tier four the
toughest tier out of the
tiering system and then very quickly uh
we moved into the national
this very severe lockdown that we have
been enduring
over the past few months so uh
yes of course we follow the advice but
of course the scientists themselves
were also learning rapidly and i'm sure
susan
will address that in her comments on
just before we
just before we speak to dr hopkins you
know you say that you moved to the
national lockdown very quickly
after discovering the new variant it was
17 days after that you introduced the
national lockdown
if you look at as well looking back
throughout the pandemic the first
lockdown was imposed 25 days after
imperial said
that half a million people could die of
the virus the november lockdown was 45
days after sage said
a circuit breaker could be considered so
you can see why people like harley might
think that actually there has been this
delay
well as i said we we moved rapidly if
you go back
uh to march uh we we very quickly moved
uh when we got the information uh in
terms of
uh what to do about the virus but as i
say
uh it's you know sometimes of course uh
you know when you look back you think
well if i'd known that then may i may
have done things slightly differently
but we were learning as we were having
to also make these really tough
decisions
on a daily basis uh as were the
scientists
you know the the uh sage advisors
didn't know as much as they do today you
know if you go back to
easter last year and they looked at i
think
six care homes and very quickly
discovered
uh and i think they refer to them as the
easter six
this asymptomatic spread of the virus
was a real problem uh we very quickly
then moved on
uh our you know what we did about care
homes and the further protection we then
added
uh to uh the uh residents of of care
homes elderly residents of canada okay
let's bring in dr hopkins
at this point shall we and the minister
they're saying that scientists were
learning through
two throughout the pandemic and that is
true isn't it it's been a learning
process
for all of us but do you think that
quicker action could have saved lives
i think we know at each point that
you know when we go into national
restrictions
that it's really important to do that to
reduce hospitalizations and reduce the
number of deaths
it's always a difficult decision i think
for government to make when that occurs
as clearly you know the risks to the
population of not having their
livelihood
of uh the complications of having to
stay at home for some individuals and
the mental health risks are there as
well
however the key point is is that when
the case numbers are rising
then measures are required to flatten
the curve
and bring case numbers right back down
again do you think
uh dr hopkins that if we'd moved faster
in the winter
lives could have been saved in the
second wave
so i think it will the fullness of time
will tell us
how many lives we could have saved um i
think that we
know the government moved on the 18th of
december particularly in london the
southeast and
kent where their virus was rising
rapidly and we also know that the
the spread of the virus over the
christmas week meant that the government
needs to go into further national
measures after that
it's a difficult decision for government
but from
looking at it from a clinician and a
scientist
it's always important to follow
the evidence when national restrictions
are required
let's go back to carly at this point
shall we carly you've been listening to
the answers you've heard what have you
made with the response
um i'm not really sort of happy with the
response i've received
um i just think that
the scientists where they are more
clinically trained you know they know
what they know what they're talking
about more than what the government do
and i think you know we should have been
listening to them a lot more
minister what would you like to say in
response
carly i promise you um if you talk to
uh you're hearing from susan hopkins
here if you talk to jonathan van tam
deputy chief medical officer chris
whittie the
chief medical officer of course patrick
valance the chief scientific advisor
we listen all the time to
their advice and of course their
deliberations with the sage committee
uh but you know the whole world carly's
learning about this
uh virus uh the virus
has changed so we we began with a
different virus and then
in the winter had a bavarian that was
more infectious
uh and of course there is no doubt that
nobody gets every decision right we will
have
an inquiry we have we're good at these
things in this country we do learn
uh rapidly through our inquiry process
and we will look at all these things and
learn the lessons
the important thing now carly is to
focus on
making sure we vaccinate uh as quickly
as we can those that are most vulnerable
so i
make sure the top four categories that
the joint committee the experts have
told us
the joint committee on vaccination and
immunization have told us we have to
protect
that's 88 of deaths carly they
will have their first dose and their
protection
by uh this coming monday and then we
keep going down the list
all the way to uh categories five six
seven eight and nine
that's 99 of death so this is a race
against death
and uh vaccines are our way out of this
and of course ultimately we offer the
vaccine to the whole of the abbot
population
and when your turn comes i hope uh you
will also
take the vaccine because it protects you
protects your family your friends and
your community as well
okay let's go to our next question now
uh shall we i'm looking for olivia
iron monger for our next question i
think you've got a question on borders
hello hi olivia nice little wave
hey hi hi um why didn't we close our
borders and not let anyone in and out of
the country like australia did
and would we be in the same mess now if
we had done that
would the uk be in less of a mess now if
it closed
its borders like australia uh mr harwin
thank you olivia so uh some
of you may remember at the outset
actually
we triaged people coming in from wuhan
and from the whole of china
and then of course italy and then iran
if you remember
but very quickly the advice
uh coming back to us was actually
including the who
uh the world health organization saying
that more resources
should be spent on other interventions
because the virus was beginning to
spread so rapidly
across the whole of europe including the
united kingdom
uh now this year as we
uh have gone into this more severe
lockdown and of course the vaccines are
being deployed rapidly we're at 13.5
million people now
with the first uh dose of the vaccine as
of yesterday
we have strengthened our border controls
the first thing
we did as did by the way germany and
canada look at
pre-departure testing so we now have
pre-departure testing
we've uh closed uh our
borders to uh those countries that are
most concerned where we're seeing
those variants coming from so they can't
travel here i think there was some data
today
from heathrow saying uh that travels
down by almost 90 percent
and of course we've introduced uh both
home quarantine
and hotel quarantine so you have to have
three tests a preparation test
a test after two days and a test after
eight days
and of course home and hotel quarantine
i'm keen to bring in uh dr hopkins
at this point um nadim zahari that was
talking
about some countries having stricter
restrictions but
in the 21st of january sage warned
geographically targeted travel bans
cannot be relied upon to stop the
importation of new variants
if we're going to get serious about
stopping new variants into the country
do we need blanket
travel blends or blanket hotel
quarantines
so i think quarantine is absolutely the
most important thing um
quarantined 10-day quarantine will
really reduce the risk to the population
whether that be in hotels or at home
but people need to do it effectively so
the most important thing about it is
that if you're going to quarantine you
need to not leave the house
not have contact with anyone else adding
testing to that will reduce the risk
even further so that when people come
out of
of that 10-day period with the negative
test on day 8
then the risk to the population is
absolutely minimal i think the reason
to have a phased approach between hotels
and home quarantine
is so that we can ensure those coming
from higher risk countries where we know
variants are circulating
get the tests rapidly and that we can
get the results back from those tests
and act on them if necessary
quarantine's most important to wherever
it is at the same time though you say
quarantine's the most important wherever
it is
but how can you trust people to actually
quarantine um daddy harding for example
recently said that
around 20 000 people a day aren't
self-isolating
when they're told to buy test and trace
so unless people are in a hotel
how do you know that they're staying at
home
well that's that that's a decision i
think for people to know that they're
putting other people at risk
and you know i think we have to um have
adult conversations with each other and
recognize that
um clearly you know there's there's also
a penalty that governments has
introduced
um but i think that the most important
thing is is that if
you've come from another country then uh
you should isolate for ten days
um to reduce the risk to others um i
think that equally when you've got
symptoms or your contact with the case
here
you need to isolate to reduce the most
diabetes and dr hopkins do you think the
idea of vaccine passports is a good one
so i think we don't know enough about
the vaccine yet to talk about vaccine
passports we're only starting to learn
about the
what it might do to reduce transmission
we are
clear that the vaccine reduces the risk
of
hospitalization and the risk of death
which is why it's being prioritized in
those older groups
however until we have further evidence
on transmission
their talk of our passwords is a little
bit too premature
we need to get the case numbers down we
need to get the vast majority of the
adult population vaccinated
and then we'll be able to assess that in
more detail okay
and mr sahari i wondered you could you
might be able to clear something up for
me on vaccine passports because sky news
understands
there's a ministerial meeting tomorrow
to discuss plans to introduce
vaccine and testing certificates for
when international travel is open again
now
i talked to you about this on sunday and
you said
we're certainly not looking to introduce
vaccine passports it would be
discriminatory
and the right thing to do is to make
sure people come forward to be
vaccinated because they want it
rather than it for it to be mandatory
through a passport so can you just clear
it up
what's going on absolutely uh so
so um we don't mandate vaccination in
the united kingdom i think that's right
we do it by persuasion which is why
we've got one of the highest
acceptance rates of vaccination in the
adult population
in the world we about 85 percent of the
adult population
say they will very likely or most likely
take a vaccine and that's a really good
thing
and so if the of the sort of the uh uh
passport means uh you're mandating
that's not what we're
doing that's not what we will do that's
not how we do things in the uk
certification you already have the
capability obviously to have a
certificate for pre-departure testing
as we require in our country as well in
terms of our border control
and if people need to be able to
demonstrate that they've had a vaccine
their data is held of course by the
national vaccination
and immunization system and we
you have to be able to make that data
available to people if they require it
if it is something they need to show or
demonstrate
elsewhere but we have no plans for
introducing a vaccine passport in the
united kingdom
okay let's get a show of hands from our
audience at this point because
vaccine possible has been floated as
this idea of a way of getting people to
be able to travel internationally
if you're in favor of the idea of a
vaccine passport
put your hand up now
okay quite a lot of people seem to be in
favor of it vast majority that looks to
me put your hand up if you don't think
it would be a good idea
okay so there are a smattering of people
who think it would be a bad idea but
that
does look like the vast majority of
people would quite like the idea of
vaccine passports mr harwi what do you
make of that maybe you should change
your policy
well as as dr hopkins was saying
we don't yet know the impact of the
vaccines on transmission
and of course we don't mandate
vaccination we do it by persuasion by
telling people
that you know vaccines save about two to
three million people a year
worldwide they've made a real difference
to polio to
measles mumps and rubella and now to uh
covert it's our way out of this
pandemic is to vaccinate ourselves to
protect ourselves protect our families
and our communities but it's not uh
mandatory in the uk
of course we will ways of providing
people with the evidence that they have
been vaccinated which
which is held in their health uh you
know with their where their general
practice
or in their uh health information under
the national vaccination immunization
system
i'm keen to just ask you both quickly
lots of people think about booking
summer holidays at the minute have
either of you booked a summer holiday
and if you have where have you booked it
dr hopkins you first i haven't booked a
whole day
uh i'd really like to get to visit my
parents in ireland
but i'd only do that if i can travel
safely and if there's a
corridor between ireland and england and
i'm able to do that uh
in a way that can protect my parents as
well uh so
i haven't booked anything yeah
definitely i think it's speaking for a
lot of people with family abroad who
they're probably desperate to see
mr zaharia how about you have you got a
any summer holiday plans
no i haven't um and i'll tell you for
why sophie this has been
uh you know the most severe lockdown
that we've asked the nation
to endure uh it's been really tough it
continues to be tough
this virus loves social interaction
which is why
we're asking people not to have that
social interaction however hard it is
you know we are all
humans are pro-social animals we love
that social interaction and we have you
know people have made an incredible
effort
which is why we're seeing the numbers
come down but they're still far too high
there's still over 25 000 people in
hospital with
covered tonight um and it would be
premature
before we see really reliable robust
data of the
impact of the vaccination program and of
course
of the ability to surge
testing and then isolate rapidly as
we're doing in places like woking and
colchester with the new variant that we
have discovered
there from uh south africa um so
it's premature i think at this stage for
a government minister
to um uh without having the data
available
i think the right thing to do is for the
prime minister to
uh come to parliament and to the nation
uh uh on the 22nd
of february to set out the roadmap first
of all for reopening schools on the 8th
of march
and then beyond reopening the economy
gradually
we'll then we can begin to think about
uh things like holidays okay now we've
had lots of questions
sent in and i just want to read you this
one that we had from
tim in doncaster now tim's mother died
of coronavirus
in november she was living in the care
home and tim hadn't been able to see her
for eight months she'd been separated
from her family
this is tim's question if the government
claims that wave one
lessons were learned and applied please
can you explain
why january the 2021 saw the highest
weekly death rate in care homes from
covet 19
since may last year dr hopkins
why did january 2021 see the highest
weekly cover deaths in care homes
since may 2020
so i i think that it's really sad and
i'm i'm
very sorry to hear that news i think
that the reason for the highest weekly
death in care homes was because we had a
massive resurgence of cases
um in the country in december late
december and early january
with probably three times the amount of
cases in the country in early january
that we saw at the peak in in
april and sadly that some of those
individuals will have got got the
infection um
from people coming into the care home
and then spread it
throughout every action has been taken
to
introduce ppe in care homes
provide safe ways of working and even
twice weekly uh
tests um in care homes with weekly pcr
tests
but even all of these things this virus
is very very infectious
and we know now how many people are
asymptomatic which is why we've
introduced this asymptomatic testing
in uh high-risk places and so i'm i'm
really sorry to hear that
um and clearly we've got more work to do
um minister around a third of covert
deaths have been
for care home residents they were able
to be discharged from hospital
without a negative test directly to care
homes and it feels like the protective
ring
that matt hancock promised wasn't put
them around put around care homes in
march
and it wasn't put around them in the
autumn either
what have you failed people in care
homes
well we you're absolutely right to say
that they are a priority they were
my number one priority so if you look at
the vaccination program
uh the first target was to vaccinate
with the first dose
k home residents and those who look
after them and we're going back to
do the second dose in march to make sure
that they are
protected um we introduced uh testing
uh as dr hopkins just described 4k homes
tim
know my heart goes out to you i lost my
uncle a few weeks ago
not in a care home but he got infected
in hospital
you know that the top four cohorts are
88 of mortality
and this new variant that
was far more infectious and dr hopkins
just described
the the quantum three times more
in january than last year
was a big big determinant factor in this
uh and i am sorry and we we've put in uh
you know over a billion pounds to care
homes to deliver
that additional protection uh from last
year
and of course both ppe and testing uh
into care homes so
um you know i i'm my heart goes out to
you tim but
um this new variant was is so much more
infectious and and clearly made life
very difficult uh
for the most vulnerable cohorts which is
why we're focusing uh
on those uh over 80s of course residents
of care homes are category one and two
uh in the privatization process
i'm very sorry as well to hear about
your uncle uh reminder that so many
families have been touched by this
dreadful virus so michael dolan says to
your family
at this point i am quite keen to get a
bit of a sense from the audience about
care homes specifically if you think
that the government has learned the
lessons on care homes
over the last year put up your hand if
you think lessons have been learned on
protecting people in care homes put your
hand up
one two three four
maybe definitely no more than ten i
don't think there
and if you don't i can see some people
shaking their heads already
if you don't think lessons have been
learned on care homes then put your hand
up now
i mean it's overwhelming i have to say
an overwhelming majority of people don't
think that
lessons been learned on on care homes
right let's move on now to our next
question shall we and it is from uh
zelika
bagan delico what's your question
yes as a british asian nurse i have
heard
much more people dying from kophid from
my own bangladeshi community
during this surge it's not only
frightening but deeply devastating to
many who have lost their loved ones
our people of ethnic minorities still
twice
as likely to be adversely affected than
those who are not
before we go to the uh to ask get the
answer for the question just quite keen
to hear a bit more about
yourself you say you're a nurse you're
obviously a key worker how have you
found the last year
um yes it's been quite tough for myself
and the family
and all of my colleagues who have been
working across both the acute
and community sector and also for my
young
children especially my son who has
missed quite a lot of education
my husband had covered it's been a real
roller coaster of emotions
it's affected everybody in our office
our homes
um a lot of people from my husband's
friends and family
um is a constant battle and
hearing all the sad news and devastation
is really quite sad and do you feel that
there's been a
increased fear in communities like the
bangladeshi community when you
hear reports that people from ethnic
minorities have been more likely to be
touched by covered
yes definitely there is much more fear
within our own community of getting
covered and dying from covid
and a lot of fear-mongering going on
with the vaccines also
um at the moment but um it's frightening
because everybody knows everybody in the
community and when they're here one
person and
another five families within days with
each other
it's um it's just devastating
thank you so much for your question
let's go um straight to our panel uh
now and mr zaharwee uh we heard zalika
talk a bit there about
vaccine hesitancy how much of a concern
is this
it's really important zalika i'm so glad
you
you are one highlighting this because
uh although we have 85 percent of the uk
adult population who
say that they will take the vaccine and
it's the highest in the world
the 15 percent who are vaccine hesitant
skew heavily towards bame communities
and
we've got a vaccine uptake strategy
working with local government
to make sure that we reach those
hard-to-reach groups we are publishing
of course
ethnicity data as well in terms of
uptake
and we want to make sure that we reach
all those groups and deal with some of
the anti-vaxx
sentiment on this in terms of the
prioritization obviously uh healthcare
frontline i hope zalika you've had your
vaccine or the offer of the vaccine
already is really important because
it's people like yourself talking to the
community about the safety of vaccines
and how important they are to keep you
safe your family safe and your community
is how we're going to get the message
across the joint committee on
vaccination immunization looked
at bame communities and whether they
were at
a greater threat from the virus and they
came down very clearly
um on the side of of the one to nine
priority which is based
very much on age of course
cohort four is clinically extremely
vulnerable
um as well as the over 70s but cohort
six
which we're about to enter five and six
is
people who are age 16 to 64 who may have
underlying conditions that would put
them at greater risk
which will hopefully pick up a lot of
other
critical workers like teachers and
police officers and shop workers who may
have underlying conditions that put them
at frisk and they can come forward
in cohort six and be vaccinated let's
leaka have you had your vaccine
yes i have had my vaccine i'm due to
have my
um second job very soon um i'm in the
process of just booking that tomorrow
morning
and my mum's had hers but she's very
hesitant to have
her second job and actually getting her
to have the first job was
um enormous amount of work to just work
her up to accept him that
it is safe for her to have it um
and a lot of persuasion had to go into
getting her to get the vaccine
because of fear it's interesting to hear
her there talking about her mom's
hesitancy i mean
mr sahara has the government really
failed to get the message out enough
that it is safe well as i said
we've been working on this uh issue the
nhs
has a very clear plan of making sure
that we reach
all communities and you'll be hearing
more from me
about this uh in the coming days we have
uh
an integrated plan with local government
to make sure that we reach
the heart to reach groups we've got 23
million pounds
uh to 60 local authorities to identify
uh
those community champions that can take
the message out
the best people are people like zalika
who are healthcare workers on the front
line
from bame communities who've had the
vaccine
they are the most effective advocates
for the vaccination program and we're
making sure almost every night
doctors nurses frontline workers who've
had the vaccine
from bme communities are sending
messages out to their communities
to demonstrate the safety of vaccines
and i'm glad i see zelika's nodding
there
uh i thank you zalika from the bottom of
my heart for
one uh being on the front line and doing
the work that you do to protect
uh all of us and those of obviously
who's suffering from covert
but also in that sort of persuasion and
getting the message out to your
community the bangladeshi community
would you be prepared to act as an
advocate seleka maybe we can
make it happen absolutely i would be
100 um they're advocating for people of
my community to go ahead and have the
vaccine for sure
okay um dr susan hopkins um
what is the evidence showing uh on
whether or not people from black and
minority ethnic groups are they more
likely
to have bad experiences with covet
so yes so we we thought in wave one and
we're still saying it now that they
have uh more likely to be admitted to
hospital more likely to
need icu admission and sadly still more
likely to die
we don't quite understand all of the
factors underlying that
and some of it is related to
other underlying infected diseases they
may have but
a lot of it seems to be unexplained um
and therefore you know our strong
recommendation for these communities
is to take up the vaccine offer as soon
as possible and thank you seleka
and that's given me some joy okay yeah i
think it has brought us all a bit of joy
actually it's a lovely uh moment they're
hearing from zeleka out of interest
if you've received a covered vaccine put
up your hand
so actually that is quite maybe about a
third
slightly more perhaps that is not bad
going i don't think
that is not by going um thank you right
let's go to our next question now and
it's on education
an issue i know that so many people feel
really strongly about uh san mateo
what's your question yeah
i would like to ask why and how
government can believe that the schools
are not one of the reasons
that often is increasing copied 19
infections i know one of my close family
friends
infected entire family got infected
because one of the child has
served as a career for the kovid19
infection
okay thank you very much for your
question let's go to the minister on
this
do you agree that opening schools could
increase the number
of covered 19 infections
sandman part of the reason that we took
the difficult decision to close schools
is because
of the household interaction that would
take place because
families mix um when they are
picking up the children uh or dropping
their children off at school we didn't
want to
uh take that decision because education
is so important
uh of course part of the reason why
we're being so careful as well
now and the prime minister said that he
will come to parliament
and address the nation uh in terms of
the road map to reopening schools
uh hopefully on the 8th of march and
then gradually reopening the rest of the
economy is because we want to be really
really careful
uh to make sure that we do it and do it
in a sustainable way
and so i think uh your question is
incredibly important
schools themselves uh are safe but it's
that social interaction
uh with that virus that
obviously were the variant that was more
infectious that led us to this difficult
decision
uh to close schools although i have to
say
and i want to just thank all teachers
because they're still open for the
children
of uh the nhs workers on the front line
and of course the
you know very vulnerable children
they're educating them in primary and
secondary
schools as we speak but we want to make
sure that we open them
safely and gradually as we see the data
and the evidence of bringing this
new variant under control i want to go
to dr hopkins on
how safe schools are but just before i
do mr sahara you're talking there about
the
fact that you're really prioritizing
schools but if you look back over the
last
year you know laptops that were promised
last spring still haven't been delivered
to vulnerable pupils ofsted for many
many months wasn't even inspecting
the work uh the school's work that they
were doing in online teaching so you've
got this disparity with different
schools providing different things
the education endowment foundation has
said that a decade's worth of progress
closing the attainment gap between
privileged and less privileged pupils
could be wiped out i mean many people
would think that when it comes to
education it hasn't been a priority it's
been forgotten
well one we got the laptops
into schools into the arms of those
children who can't afford to have them
and the families connected working with
the networks
to be able to uh not just have the
physical
hardware but also be able to connect and
get the benefits of online schooling
it's
it's tough online schooling i know it
i've got an eight-year-old
as well uh that i know how difficult
it's been for families
uh but we've also put a billion pounds
into the
uh catch-up fund and a further uh 350
million to make sure
that we do that and actually the the
educational endowment foundation
uh uh you know great guru is now uh
doing the work to make sure that catch
up does happen
um and and that we do make sure that
children especially the most vulnerable
children
in our communities in our society get
that additional help
as i say not just with the hardware but
also with
with the catch-up and the hours that
will need to go in to make sure that
they they do catch up
uh it is it is the toughest decision
we've had to take
in this pandemic uh to uh and we didn't
want to
as i say uh close schools uh two
children
uh but with the this new more um
infectious variant it was forced upon us
but as i say
we want to reopen them and reopen them
safely and sustainably
dr hopkins is there a risk that if
schools are reopened on the 8th of march
as
boris johnson has suggested that the r
rate the reproduction rate of the virus
could be pushed to buff one
so uh schools we've always said that
schools should be
the last to close and press to open and
the reason for that is that they
have a small impact on or um but
actually
the most important thing is is that it
to weigh up the pros and cons of having
school
children in education for their mental
health their physical health
and obviously their long-term societal
well-being uh
and i think that you know the the
infections in schools have been low
um on average reflecting what's
happening in the community
uh we've seen small numbers of cases in
schools but nothing like sort of the
outbreaks we've seen in other closed
institutional settings
i think that when we come to march with
this newer more infectious virus
that we have now we'll need to watch
them very very closely
um including i think by you know
watching how we can increase
testing as already has happened with
teachers in both secondary schools and
primary schools now
but also looking at how we can get the
communities to test
so that we reduce the infection risk the
lower the amount of infection that's out
there in the community
than the lower risk that there is of
transmitting at the school gates
in school bus on the way to school in
the playground
i think in the classrooms teachers have
done a great amount of work to reduce
transmission
keeping the desks apart keeping doors
open
and making sure that school children
don't mix between classes
and all of that has been very effective
to prevent there to be rising outbreaks
in schools
okay well let's get our next question in
uh now shall we
and it's from nicholas canavan who i
believe is a year
13 uh student what's your experience
been
over the last year someone who's in the
a levels hoping to go to university
what's it been like
well we've had all our lessons um online
in the last year
and even when the pandemic the
transmission rates were quite low we
were still only in one day a week so
it's been difficult definitely and have
you worried that it could affect your
chances of getting the grades that you
deserve your chances of going to
university
absolutely yeah i think there's
definitely a worry from students my age
that
the exam mess of last year is going to
repeat itself
and definitely that uncertainty is not
good for students
yeah you talking about the exam mess um
that happened last year have you been
reassured by what the government has
said so far on exams that you've still
got worries about it
not so much we haven't really so we
still don't have clarity on
what exactly will make up our teacher
assessed grades so
you know there's still much uncertainty
with virtually everyone in my class
um so you're talking about the anxiety
you feel the lack of clarity on exams
let's put your points directly to
the minister now shall we nicholas kind
of asking why is it still unclear
how school grades will be assessed
nicholas i look you're absolutely right
to say it's been really difficult
and online education
uh has proved to be challenging and i
uh thank you for persevering for
focusing for absolutely staying
on course with your work um what we've
tried to do what the secretary state
has tried to do is work with the
education
regulator to make sure that um the
teacher assessment is done in a fair way
it's done in a way
that makes sure that you get the just
rewards for your hard work in a really
difficult
year uh for students and for young
people
sorry to come in sorry to come
why hasn't this work been done already
it's been clear for a long time that
exams
could be cancelled why haven't you got
your ducks in the row and sorted this
out already
so that people like nicholas don't have
this uncertainty
well as i said because the the secretary
of state for education wants to make
sure
that the uh regulator works as closely
with schools with teachers to get this
right so that we make sure that no child
feels no student feels uh that uh
you know their work has gone um
unnoticed
or uh under rewarded um and that they
all get
the the the the assessment
that gives them the the right outcomes
so that you know beyond this difficult
year they can rebuild
and keep going and hopefully get a
nicholas will get a great degree i'm
sure
and do incredibly well okay let's bring
in our next
question shall we
let's bring in our next question now
shall we uh marcel
moth has got a question i think what
would you like to ask
yes looking back to june 2020
i think we can agree going on holiday
and eating out to help out was too soon
how can we be sure that we don't repeat
the same mistakes
thank you how can we be sure we don't
repeat the same mistakes i'm going to go
to
dr hopkins first here did
the eat out to help out scheme and
people going on holidays last summer
lead to a rise in infections
so i think that every social interaction
leads to a rise in
infections it's the infections rising in
the community um
in parts of the summer it was very low
levels but as we got towards the end of
the summer we started to see some
signals that the infections were
beginning to rise again
that definitely rose at the start start
of september
and continues then over the last number
of months um i think that
we will need to watch very carefully as
we ease up in these national
restrictions
taking time to watch and monitor at each
phase
and i think that once we get to a very
low level of community
we'll need to have ongoing measures in
place until the adult population are
vaccinated
what those measures are we'll it'll
we'll have to watch and see
but i think it's really important that
we keep the rates as low
as possible um for as long as possible
next this year so do you think with that
in mind that we're actually going to see
a more restricted summer this year
despite the vaccinations
than we did last year so i think it's
really difficult to say
i mean some some of the weeks last year
there was really really low amounts of
infection
um uh you know less than two and ten
thousand people were infected at one
point
in the summer so that means that the
likelihood of you meeting somebody was
extremely low
um but it starts to increase and i think
you know one of the things that we've
learned is that
when people go on holidays perhaps they
drop their guard a bit
perhaps they mingle a bit closer uh
and they mingle in groups and that may
be one of the areas where
spread of infection can occur so i think
we are going to have to have some
measures in place until the whole
population are vaccinated at least
all of the adult population and even
then i think we'll need to know more
about transmission before we can
release everything and get back to life
as it was
just quickly did universities going back
have a
impact on the rising rates that we saw
so we saw that when universities went
back there were um cases and outbreaks
in
in the universities themselves and
actually in some universities had large
outbreaks
um clearly related to socialization and
mixing of those universities
and large groups of students i think
it's challenging when you live in halls
with a couple of hundred people living
in the same building and the mixing that
can occur in those places
there were some spillovers into the
wider community
but actually the majority of them were
contained from the universities and
universities actually started to
understand what they should do and how
they should do it
and we saw very few cases in students
when they
were all tested out as they went home
for christmas
and actually the large amount of testing
that universities did at that time
found a very very low amount of
infections in universities at that point
showing that they had learned the
lessons okay well let's go to nadine's
hallway now
shall we did we open up too quickly
too readily at last summer and is the
government
learning from those mistakes well i
think you've just heard
from uh dr robinson that
uh the etaps help out uh scheme had you
know
very low levels of uh uh infection rates
through this socializing
process um i think the really important
message i want to get across
sophie and thank you myself for the
question is as we continue
to vaccinate people you know we're at
13.5 million people the first dose
you've got to be really careful because
it's three weeks after that so
if uh monday the 15th of february is the
first four cohorts which is 88
of mortality you've got to then work
three weeks beyond that so
that takes you to the first week of
march and then if
the end of april is the top one to nine
phase one which is 99 percent of
mortality
then you've got to go three weeks so
you're into and you know third week of
may
before people are protected you know we
saw some evidence
sadly in israel of early um
uh you know people who have the first
dose would have that sort of
vaccine euphoria and start going out
immediately and interacting
that caused them to then catch the virus
we have to be really really careful
hence why we are deliberately
uh following you know every step of this
uh very carefully and the prime minister
will set out
at the roadmap for the opening of the
economy on the 22nd of february
but you know we have to keep you know
learning and as i said
at the opening of your program uh sophie
the
virus we uh were grappling with back
last year in march is a is a is a very
different virus than the one
that was more infectious that we
then got in december on the 18th and
acted
rapidly on the 19th of december uh
moving to
uh tier four and then very quickly uh
before christmas into the national
severe lockdown
uh we obviously saw the eat out help
scheme as a way of trying to boost the
economy seven and ten thousand
restaurants so they could close in 2021
according to a uk hospitality survey
should we be expecting to see
unemployment rising this year
well clearly small businesses have had a
really difficult time including of
course the hospitality industry
not lost on the member of parliament for
stratford on avon i can tell you
because my local economy is so
reliant on the hospitality sector
they did everything they can to make
sure that
their uh pubs and restaurants
were safe and and coveted but of course
we've had to take these
additional measures because of this new
variant we've put 280
billion pounds into the economy and
another 55 billion
this year that the chancellor is
committing to the economy we've got a 30
billion pound
plan for jobs and you'll hear more from
the chancellor on
the 3rd of march when he stands up in
parliament dispatch box and delivers
the budget and front and center has
always been to protect his many jobs
12 million jobs were protected through
the furlough scheme
that the even the imf uh sophie
uh have said that the uk's economic
rescue package for businesses is one of
the best in the world so
and we continue to do more and more as
we the chances just done recently in
extending the different schemes
of help for business okay we're talking
a bit about
reopening the economy about lifting
restrictions i'm interested
to get a bit of a share of hands about
how people are feeling we've been living
under these restrictions for
an awfully long time who who's
feeling they're struggling in a bit of a
bit right now who's finding things tough
i'll put my hand up i think it's quite a
tough time for us
not everyone most people not everyone
who are the
who are the people who feel you know
what i'm doing okay the vaccines are
going out i'm feeling more positive
put your hands up if you are one of
these people
so that's that's good to see they've got
some positivity some waving as well
which is uh
really nice to see a couple of shaking
heads too though
right let's get our next question this
is janet candy you've got a question for
us what is it
hi yeah thank you well i hear all this
but you know there is still a climate
emergency
not for my life or not for yours maybe
but for the next generation
the government has found that magic
monetary
and poured billions into fighting covid
but can some of this determination and
generosity
be extended to tackling climate change
okay will the government treat climate
change with the same determination as
covert 19 the domestic harvey janet
that's a great question and
um the prime minister in the middle of
this covert
pandemic set out a 10-point plan on
climate we are this year
hosting cop 26 in uh
scotland and my fellow minister alok
sharma
actually stepped away from being
secretary of state for business
to take on the role of president of
cop26
and is making sure that we bring the
world together and
the prime minister had a great
conversation with the
president of the united states who's now
also committing
heavily to uh making sure we do
something uh
on uh this subject that is material at
cop26
let me give you one example janet of the
work the prime minister outlined
on his ten-point plan so today to come
in then very quick
just very give me 10 seconds
we account for 36 of the whole of the
planet's
offshore wind energy generation today
the prime minister wants us to quadruple
that because he wants by 2030
for every home to be powered by offshore
wind
he says to the united kingdom
that was definitely more than 10 seconds
i'm going to ask where is the money
coming from
because thanks to kovic 19 we could be
seeing the biggest hit to the economy
since the great frost all the way back
in 1709 where's the money
absolutely so another really good
question so when you invest in assets
you're building
assets uh like uh the offshore wind
infrastructure
or other uh renewables that we're doing
for creating the greenest energy
production
in the world they are assets they're on
the asset side of the balance sheet and
our commitment is to spend
640 billion to almost two-thirds of a
trillion on infrastructure
and again you'll hear more from the
chancellor on this on another march
i'm keen to get a thought from you dr
hopkins as well the questions about
throwing forward about future plans
what do you think one of the big lessons
has been for
the country on what we should be
focusing on prioritizing going forward
so i think we have learned a lot about
pandemic preparedness
and emergency response and ensuring that
we have
enough resources in the system that
allows us to be flexible and agile
when an emergency like this is thrown at
us
we need to ensure that we are able to
have conversations about behavioral
science
so that we know how to um have
conversations with the public
we need to ensure that we are world
leading in data science so that we have
the right data to help make those
decisions
uh and i think even in in terms of
climate change so climate change will
will and probably come impact on us
um with new viruses new diseases and new
threats
so we have to be ready for that and
prepare for it one of the things that
some scientists have said over the last
couple of nights is that we should be
prepared for some low level restrictions
for some time to come what's your view
on that
well i think life has changed and we
will have
low level restrictions for some time i
think that until everyone is vaccinated
we'll definitely have some low level
restrictions
i think we will all need to watch and
see what happens next winter
we don't know the duration of the
vaccine response
we are likely i think to have at least
some people re-vaccinated in the autumn
and i think until we get through next
winter this won't feel like we're going
in the right direction okay thank you
both
very much now before we finish tonight i
want to ask our audience one last
question but before
that one word about the information
that's underpinned as special programs
this week now sky news has compiled a
detailed analysis of
every significant moment during the
pandemic it's a comprehensive timeline
of a year like no other and tonight
we're going to be publishing it in full
on our website for anyone and everyone
to access
if you would like to and you can explore
that the purpose of this week's programs
has really been to examine whether we're
learning the lessons of the last year so
i've got a final question to our virtual
studio audience a show of hands if you
like
given everything you've seen and heard
this evening over the previous two
nights
do you think lessons have been learned
the right lessons have been learned from
the last year put your hand up
if you think that we've learned the
right lessons from the pandemic
wow that is not very many at all okay
and a lot of shaking heads
if you don't think we've learned the
lessons put your hand up now
i'm i'm going to have to get a response
from unidentified i thought that was
pretty overwhelming people don't feel
the
lessons have been learned
well look i'm not surprised because
people
are uh feeling a lot of pain
it's not lost on this minister or the
government or the prime minister that
people are in a very severe lockdown
uh which they rightly find
difficult um we've asked people to uh
not to socially interact hands-face
space
this is a difficult time uh we continue
to persevere all i can promise you
as the vaccines deployment minister i
have an amazing team i stand on the
shoulders of
heroes in the nhs family in our armed
forces
the army of volunteers 80 000
vaccinators have come forward 200 000
people
to be marshals and stewards and so on uh
and of course
the the vaccine scientists who produce
this vaccine
i will continue to protect as
many people as quickly as possible in
those most vulnerable cohorts
and protect the whole of the adult
population as quickly as possible
because that is our
pandemic we're out of time and thank you
both very much for your contributions
tonight
mr sahari dr hopkins and also thank you
very much to
our audience you have had a great range
of questions some really lively debates
thank you so much and i hope you enjoyed
it and thank you for being
so lively as well thank you and thank
you for watching at home there's much
more analysis
insight and research about the covert
crisis on the sky news app
that was covert crisis learning the
lessons
thanks again for watching and good night
[Music]
you